sam has
a six girl rotation where's sam at are
you there
sam okay yo what up yo
what's up bro yeah it's good to talk to
you so
um i'm actually really glad that you
picked me because i just finished your
book
okay and listening to your book was
actually one of the main reasons
that pushed me to realize that i'm
wasting a bunch of my time spinning
plates
because even if you're only seeing a
bunch of the girls once a month
the time that you have to dedicate to
them it really just sucked up way too
much so
i kind of had a realization where the
one that i kept coming back to
the cream that rose to the top yep i
decided to friend zone all of them and
i'm one week
into the ltr and so basically
a big concern that i have is that um i
am a dj producer
that is on the come up things are going
extremely well it's not how i make my
money i have a business
and that's going insanely well i'm going
to clear seven figures this year
which is older 28 okay so it's pretty
crazy to me everything's
couldn't be going better and i had a ton
of fun the past two years
basically getting out of my blue pill
life
realizing your content after i almost
got married
really became the best alpha version of
myself i'm on top of the world right now
but obviously i have a lot of concerns
that i'm getting into this ltr
where i'm actually at the point i'm
going to be able to start traveling
around the country in the world
playing clubs 30 and that's another
thing
okay okay yeah how long were you dating
her
so we were seeing each other we were
seeing each other since july
like uh we were having sex since july
but we were friends because she moved
into my old
unit and was getting my mail for about
two years now
and so literally a good way to describe
her
um i would say she's like a seven she's
like very cute but not like sexy
i put myself at like a nine okay so
she is absolutely in love with me and
does
everything that i need to get done i
kind of describe her
almost like pepper potts you know from
iron man she's like a really good
assistant you know what i'm saying
gwyneth paltrow right exactly exactly
exactly so she's just kind of like in
the background she thinks about things
you know it fills a lot of the gaps that
i don't feel as far as like a
strategy and planning perspective you
know what i'm saying more of a macro
she's more of a micro kind of
thing so sam who who initiated the talk
like where do we stand
me and she actually was kind of uh
because i realized that that seeing all
the girls again they were kind of energy
vampires sucking up my time and it was
just
too much i i don't need it for my ego
anymore
so i'm trying to figure out how to
maximize productivity because all the
time that i spend not
on my business is in music production as
i'm trying to grow the brand and blow
that up
so i mean like you've read my book so
two things you should know right away is
don't date women that are older than you
and the second thing is let her initiate
the talk
damn so what's the question here
so the question is is that um that
basically
if i understand all the principles that
i have the burden of performance
and that i am going to uh
be the one that i i guess what it is is
that i don't want to give up
the ability to have those random
one-night stands
as you know i'm going out and playing
shows and doing my thing
and she kind of understands that but at
the same time it's like this
kind of uh awkward i don't want to
flaunt it in her face of like hey
i'm not actively seeking out other
girlfriends but
you know when i'm playing in other
countries and things like that
and i have fans and you're not there
with me it's just known as long as i
wear
like a condom you know i'm probably
gonna be hitting it so it's kind of like
a
can this work if that's my state of mind
and how should i kind of
uh approach the ltr um
going into it well um
you're approaching it the right way um
you're basically telling her like
uh i'm not monogamous and i'm not gonna
be monogamous but uh i'm not going to
put your health at risk
and um the other thing that women don't
want is they don't want to be
embarrassed so
you don't like you know this is
something that um
esther perel summarized in one of her
books when she was kind of
contrasting north american uh
culture versus european and in european
culture
women typically look the other way like
it's almost expected if you're a high
value guy that you've got a mistress or
or you've got a side piece um but you're
not
supposed to bring them to like one of
the restaurants that you bring your wife
and kids to you're not supposed to bring
them to
uh places where you might embarrass her
to friends or family members sort of
thing so i mean if you're going about it
when you're traveling doing your djing
um you know you're wrapping it up and
and
and she's okay with that then there's
really nothing to talk about
um she might she might try to express
some concern
you know at a later date or she might
change her stance on it
um but just stay firm on it i mean if
that's what you want to do then you've
set the tone at the start of the
relationship
you're not hiding anything so just carry
on with it i love it and then my last
question would be i'm
okay with the concept of eventually one
day getting married but i would want to
never want to get married
where the state has any kind of a say
where i can get divorced it would almost
be like a fake marriage
it's like hey we're getting married just
for the you know but i'm never going to
put my name on paper
um is there do you have any advice on
like actually
going through with something like that
other than talking to
i'm in georgia um
i don't know anybody in georgia that's
that's structured that way but you'd
want to talk to a family lawyer there
um look for a guy that thinks outside of
the box like
like don't go for the fuddy-duddy old
guy that's you know charging
you know thousand bucks an hour billable
um you know do the conventional you know
divorce [ __ ] look for a younger guy
that understands your lifestyle choice
and
um the most important thing really
though is
i mean if you're going to live in a way
that the state views as a marriage
and you've listened to my book i have a
chapter on marriage and the title of
that chapter is why smart men don't
marry
i'm not saying that you can't uh or that
you shouldn't but smart men you
typically don't marry because it exposes
you to unnecessary risk
exactly so that being said the whole
point of living with a check and getting
to that position really should be to
have kids
because she's good mother stock and you
want her to raise your children
and have a positive influence and
basically
take care of stuff so you can go out and
chase excellence problem with that
though is
it doesn't matter what you do generally
speaking if you live in the west
the state's going to look at it as a
marriage at some point anyway
so you're gonna have to talk to a family
lawyer on that in georgia
and see what you can the best thing that
you could do really is
leave a leave a hostile state for a more
friendly state
um there's there's friendlier states out
there like florida
you know for example is less hostile
towards fathers
there's there's no state or province in
the west that i know of
that's friendly to fathers meaning
they'll do things to benefit
dad they just do less harmful [ __ ] to
dad
at the exit um so if you have the
ability to maneuver and you can live
somewhere else
i'd probably suggest moving to a state
that's friendlier to fathers
there's there's a lot more that you can
do to that and i could spend hours on it
i've i've
got some notes here on a course that i'm
working on on vetting for mother stock
because this one
one question that comes up a lot with
guys is like how do i not
like how do i have kids and not screw up
my life right i'm like the point that
you're talking about with marriage is
is the point to have kids or is it too
mary
uh it kind of is like a it's it's to
have kids but at the same time it's also
like
a because women don't want to be a bears
kind of thing like i've been with this
guy for
so long it needs to be outwardly you
know like the appearance
that we're married kind of thing but i'm
not going to budge to allow myself to
get divorced raped
it's kind of where i'm going you're
trying to find like a happy middle
ground
yeah and you're going to find that that
that that happy middle ground is going
to be
difficult to land on and even then it's
a moving target because
um you know there's this old saying that
not all women will destroy a man
in family court but all women can if
they want to
so you want to make sure that you don't
give her that opportunity
uh to to take that tool out of her
toolbox i mean if she changes her mind
one day like let's say
she pops out two kids you're you know
you're the world's greatest dj you know
and you're traveling around the world
you're making bucks deluxe and you're
playing raves and all this kind of stuff
and
she's like [ __ ] it this guy makes you
know 10 million dollars last year
you know he's banging all these hot
younger chicks and here i am raising his
kids
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna take half
a [ __ ] in the kids too right
um you wanna you know you wanna minimize
that
exposure risk as much as possible so um
consider moving to to a place that's
less hostile towards fathers and
do whatever you can to lawyer it up so
that you've got the risk minimized as
much as possible too
um i should have that course later on
this year out and it's going to have a
lot of good information in it so keep an
eye out for that
awesome well i appreciate a lot and uh
good advice about the
not wanting to be embarrassing and i'm
glad you narrated the book did a great
job
appreciate it bro thank you and hey
listen do me a favor leave a quick
review on amazon it helps me out a ton
too
done i'll do it right now all right man
rich appreciate it bye
you